grundlagenforschung gelenke knacken aus
einem vollkommen anderen grund
e-zigaretten überschreiten aroma
höchstwerte und raub in mexiko beute
radioaktives material das sind drei der
themen jetzt in den top 50
du machst dir deine gelenke kaputt wer
kennt den satz nicht wenn man als kind
die finger knacken ließ jetzt wurde
dieses knacken ein weiteres mal genau
untersucht und die daraus gewonnenen
erkenntnisse stellen alles auf den kopf
bereits 140 beschäftigte man sich mit
der thematik 1971 wurde dann die bisher
geltende erklärung des knacken gefunden
grund für das geräusch sei laut den
forschern damals blasen in der
gelenkflüssigkeit die dort kollabieren
gregory krawtschuk von der university of
alberta hat zusammen mit seinen kollegen
ein neues experiment durchgeführt mit
hilfe eines mrt nahmen sie das knacken
von zehn verschiedenen fingergelenken
auf aus den daraus entstandenen
aufnahmen konnten sie folgende schlüsse
ziehen
das geräusch entsteht gar nicht beim
angenommenen kollabieren sondern
vielmehr beim entstehen der blase sobald
die gelenke sich voneinander entfernen
reicht die vorhandene gelenkflüssigkeit
irgendwann nicht mehr aus um den raum
zwischen den gelenken zu füllen also
muss ich die gelenkflüssigkeit trennen
und dabei entsteht dann diese
sogenannten blase so schnell oder lücke
dass man es hört also hier sowie zwei
ende zusammen war das so ist das so zu
sagen ob das knacken nun schädlich ist
oder vielleicht gar keine auswirkung hat
das konnten die forscher noch nicht
erklärt
der seltenste wahl der welt auf der
roten liste der gefährdeten tierarten
steht unter anderem der hurra war erst
neun exemplare dieser art wurden
weltweit gesichtet diese art besitzt
einen schmal korpus und eine große
gebogene flosse auf dem rücken bisher
nichts besonderes überleben im meer
sagen außer dass sie sich über das er
sich von plankton und grill ernährt und
zu der über art der bartenwale zählen
und aber für diese art eine untypische
kopfform aufweisen
das westaustralische umweltministerium
meldete jetzt dass ein solcher war nun
in australien an der westküste wegen
eines tropensturms an land gespült
worden ist es handelt sich um ein fast
sechs meter langes junges weibchen der
fund sei weltweit von großer bedeutung
so der im umweltminister westaustraliens
2003 wurde der humor war das erste mal
in der wissenschaft notiert bis 2003
dachte man dass es ein breit wahl ist
bei den a-proben viel aber eben auf dass
es eine neue art sein müsse und
wissenschaftler machen sie jetzt daran
endlich mehr über diese art zu erfahren
sind e-zigaretten gefährlich für
nahrungsmittel gibt es ja bestimmte
grenzwerte für den anteil an
aromastoffen die nicht überschritten
werden dürfen e-zigaretten gelten nun
mal nicht als nahrungsmittel und seiten
sind daher von diesen richtlinien nicht
betroffen im jahr 2014 habe der
e-zigaretten umsatz bei rund 66
milliarden euro betragen so wird
berichtet und bisher wusste aber niemand
so wirklich ob sich in den e zigaretten
gefahren verbergen sie gelten ja
meistens als ungefährliche alternative
zu den zigaretten etiketten danken
besonders aufgrund der großen auswahl an
aroma sorten eine große beliebtheit bei
rauchern eine studie zeigte dass man im
internet in etwa 6800 sorten bestellen
kann wahnsinn
die in den sorten verwendeten
aromastoffe galten bisher als
ungefährlich da sie sehr häufig in
nahrungsmitteln vorkommt nun ist man
e-zigaretten ja nicht wie beispielsweise
eben alle gucken was man inhaliert die
stoffe was für uns menschen bedeutet
damit hat sich ein forscherteam also was
das für uns bedeutet der forscherteam
der portland state university im us
bundesstaat oregon in einer studie
befasst und die forscher die unterzogen
30 erhoben für e zigaretten einer
genaueren untersuchung und dabei wurde
gemessen dass viele der aromen den
grenzwert teilweise doppelt
überschreiten zudem könnten sich beim
verdampfen der aromen noch weitere
schädliche substanzen entwickeln so die
forscher sie fordern die herstellern und
auf sich richtlinien zu setzen und auf
die produkte eine inhaltsangabe zu
schreiben
radioaktiver raub in mexiko am montag
wurde im bundesstaat tabasco iridium 192
von einem lastwagen beschuldigen 192 ist
ein radioaktives material ist strahlt
gammastrahlen aus ungenutzten 192 vor
allem in der industrie zur untersuchung
von materialien gelagert wird ihr reden
192 größtenteils in tabletten die
umgeben von einer wand aus
abgereichertem uran in großen gefäß
liegen wenn man mit diesem material in
berührung kommt kann es enormen schaden
anrichten und bis zum tod führen
in mexiko wurden schon öfter lkw mit
solchen ladungen gestohlen ohne dass die
räuber kenntnisse davon hatten was sie
denn da so durch die gegend fahren und
das ist die gefahr wenn halt diese
substanzen dann in die hände von laien
geraten
die ms wissenschaft ist wieder unterwegs
ein schiff rund um das thema wissen
schafft zukunft des städtebaus und vor
allem wie diese städte dann
funktionieren könnten das tut mit einer
außergewöhnlichen ausstellung durch
deutschland und österreich im inneren
des schiffes kann man auf interaktive
weise entdeckungen machen und sich
selbst ein bild davon machen wie sich
denn unsere umgebung so verändern könnte
die ms wissenschaft liegt seit april bis
september dieses jahres in vielen
deutschen und österreichischen städten
an wo das könnte unten in der video
beschreibung genau sehen
zu den städten der zukunft hat cedrick
übrigens ein videos video gemacht eine
ganze stadt in einem wolkenkratzer dazu
wirklichen und zum blog und zur app mit
täglichen wissenschafts news geht es
natürlich da und was meint ihr sollte
sich der verbraucherschutz mal näher mit
den e zigaretten befassen diskutiertes
in den kommentaren ach ja und bis dann
bleibt dran